[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the verdict is in in the federal trial
of r kelly the latest on the r b
singer's racketeering trial remembering
gabby petito how her friends and family
honored the 22 year old at her funeral
you knew gabby
she was always pretty happy girl people
gravitate towards her and the graphic
details of mark gucci's mennonite murder
trial how the attorneys set the tone in
their opening statements the defendant's
rifle fired the fatal round
to sasha's head and a pop star under
surveillance without her knowledge how
britney spears father kept tabs on her
for years long prime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome to law and crime daily i'm simon
choudhary in for brian buckmeyer along
with terry austin now we begin with a
guilty verdict in the federal trial of r
b singer r kelly we'll have so much more
on that but first hundreds come together
to celebrate the life of gabby petito as
a reality tv star joins the manhunt for
her fiance all this as it nears two
weeks since anyone has seen or heard
from brian laundry over the weekend tv's
dog the bounty hunter joined in the
search effort as laundry maintains
fugitive status laundry's parents also
handed over personal items to the fbi
that will assist in dna matching laundry
was last seen on september 14 when he
left his family home to go hiking in a
florida reserve well sources say he left
without a cell phone or wallet and since
then the 25 thousand acre property has
been searched with dive teams drones and
dogs laundry faces a federal warrant for
his arrest after allegedly using a debit
card that isn't his racking up more than
one thousand dollars in charges
after petito's death
now investigator joseph scott morgan
tells law and crime daily laundry's dna
will be used for more than just tracking
purposes
i think that they have specific dna
that's linkage between him
and her death and they're trying to
cover every potential
point along the way
he had possession of that van so long
and absent her okay
and they're looking for specific
evidence that's going to be a tie back
to this fatal event
uh you know no one knows what goes on
behind closed doors but you know i think
that whatever
end she came to and it i think that it's
going to wind up being very brutal i
think that it actually happened in the
van
meanwhile family and friends honor gabby
petito's tragic life cut short lawn
crimes angenette levy takes us inside
the memorial service for the 22 year old
mourners some from across the country
streamed into a funeral home in holbrook
new york on long island sunday to pay
their respects to gabby petito's family
and to remember the bubbly 22 year old
i don't want you guys to be sad
to be honest
you know gabby didn't live that way that
wasn't her way gabby's father joseph
petitto stood shoulder to shoulder with
her stepfather and spoke about how proud
he was of gabby he said she genuinely
loved people petito said people
gravitated toward her because of her
personality jim schmidt spoke about his
stepdaughter
gabby at 22 years old helped teach me
that you can always make money
but you can make up for lost time
gabby loved life and lived her life
every single day gabby petito's father
announced the creation of the gabby
petito foundation in her memory joseph
petitto wrote on twitter no one should
have to find their child on their own we
are creating this foundation to give
resources and guidance on bringing their
children home gabby petito was on a
cross-country adventure living out one
of her dreams when she was killed
joseph petitto urging people to remember
how gabby lived i want you to take a
look at these pictures
i want you to be inspired by that
that's what we're looking for that's
something i want to see
if there's a trip
that you guys want to take
take it
now do it now while you got to talk
joseph petitto also said during this
service that if people are in a
relationship that's really not good for
them or the best fit for them that they
should leave it and that's one of the
reasons or one of the lessons rather
that should come from this
sima all right angela let's bring in
co-host terry austin and criminal
defense attorney gigi gonzalez but
angela i do want to ask you before we
get to them do you expect to hear from
gabby petito's family anytime soon
actually sima they're expected to hold a
press conference in new york on tuesday
and they're going to talk more about the
gabby potito foundation so this will
really be uh the first time that we hear
from the family since it was announced
that her body had been found aside from
obviously at the funeral service
and terry gabby potato was laid to rest
this weekend so what are your thoughts
about this difficult and sad service
well i think this service served
multiple purposes obviously it gave the
family an opportunity to mourn but it
gave the public an opportunity to mourn
as well and they gave out prayer cards
that said let it be and that was a
tattoo that gabby actually had on her
and so i think it was
living her voice at this service and it
was enabling people to relate to her the
other purpose was i think to make it
open to see if anyone could remember
anything or see anything if they in fact
find brian laundry there is a 30 000
reward out but i think that's not even
going to be necessary because everybody
and anyone is going to be looking for
him yeah let's talk about the missing
fiance gigi we know brian laundry faces
charges related to debit cards and bank
accounts but could we expect to see more
severe charges if and when he's found
possibly brian is one of the last people
that may have seen gabby alive and we
know that their relationship was
becoming more violent in the days
leading up to her death and we also know
that the initial report says that the
manner of death is homicide so if the
investigation reveals evidence that
links brian laundry to the death of
gabby then we will definitely see more
serious charges filed against him
all right thanks so much for that let's
turn our attention to international news
and
prince andrew is served court papers
after dodging a sexual abuse lawsuit for
weeks
virginia jewfrey says the duke of york
sexually abused her when she was just 17
years old jewfrey says it happened at
three different locations two of which
were at properties owned by now deceased
pedophile jeffrey epstein well the
lawsuit was filed in early august but
for weeks the duke of york denied the
papers were served to him
last week his camp came to an agreement
with jew freeze and papers were served a
follow-up hearing is set for october
13th
while still ahead on long crime daily
the trial of mark gooch the former
united states airman accused in the
mennonite murder case but first a
verdict in the federal trial of r kelly
the latest in the r b singers
racketeering trial we have all that and
more still ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to
youtubetv today and then locate lawn
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle watch lawn crime every day
with youtube tv we put you in the jury
box
[Music]
welcome back well the fate of r kelly is
now sealed as the jury announces a
guilty verdict for the famed r b singer
after nine hours of deliberation kelly
was found guilty of all charges in his
federal trial including sex trafficking
and racketeering the racketeering charge
focuses on the enterprise that kelly
formed for said sex trafficking most of
the accusers include women who were all
under the age of 18 at the time of the
abuse
45 witnesses took the stand for the
prosecution including 11 accusers who
all testified to their disturbing
experiences with the i believe i can fly
singer
many giving emotional testimony
detailing being locked in a room with no
food or water and being forced to
perform sexual acts sentencing is still
set just a few months away on may 4th
kelly faces life in prison now amongst
all this kelly still faces federal and
state charges in chicago illinois all
right let's bring back gigi and terry
gigi kelly was found guilty on all
counts of racketeering and sex
trafficking if nothing else this stands
for great headway in the me too movement
yeah absolutely this is definitely a
conviction that is ultimately going to
lend power to the metoo movement here
you had incredibly heinous charges that
were filed against r kelly um and with
multiple victims dozens and dozens of
victims testifying against him to earn
this kind of conviction is definitely a
message to the community that this type
of violence against victims will not be
tolerated
and terry what sort of sentencing can we
expect for a conviction like this and
what's next that the singer now faces in
illinois
well the penalty under the rico is going
to be 20 years and the penalty under the
man act is another 10 years so he faces
multiple decades in prison he's only 54
so he will be 80 something if in fact he
gets the maximum for both of those
counts and as far as the charges in
illinois he faces charges in the
northern district of illinois which is a
federal court case for child pornography
but he also faces charges in state court
in illinois for sexual abuse and don't
forget he faces charges in minnesota as
well and so he is going to be dealing
with these court cases for quite some
time and my expectation is that he will
be extradited so he can face the charges
in these other cases
like we saw with harvey weinstein
actually and terry is there anything his
attorney should do
differently with these upcoming cases
you know i think they better be prepared
to deal with a similar type charge of
rico at least in that federal illinois
case so they can combat that if they
want to defend him at all
all right well coming up on long crime
daily what a security team was asked to
do to monitor britney spears
plus opening statements from arizona for
the man accused of murdering a sunday
school teacher more on the mennonite
murder trial just ahead
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily well
witnesses were called to the stand in
the trial of a united states airman
accused of murdering a mennonite woman
prosecutors say 22 22-year-old mark
gooch kidnapped and murdered 27-year-old
sasha krauss in january of last year
he's pleaded not guilty to charges of
first degree murder kidnapping and theft
grouse was last seen shopping for sunday
school supplies near her mennonite
community in new mexico
about a month later her body was found
near flagstaff arizona and at the time
guterres stationed at luke air force
base in phoenix which is only about a
two hour drive away an autopsy revealed
krauss died of blunt force trauma and a
gunshot wound to the head a crime lab
reported that the bullet taken from
krauss's skull was fired from a gun that
gooch had in his possession
cell phone records put gooch in the area
at the suspected time of the crime
previous text messages from the
defendant showed disdain towards the
mennonite community and in court on
friday the prosecution claimed gooch
sought out a mennonite woman and took
great lengths to cover up the alleged
crime conversely the defense spoke to
gooch's character detailing his past in
a wisconsin mennonite community and a
higher calling to enlist in the air
force
what will be clear
is that the defendant was there
that he abducted sasha
put her in his car
and then drove hours away
to the area
of the sunset crater national monument
mark was raised in the mennonite faith
mark went to church on sundays in the
mennonite faith as did all of his family
he went to a mennonite school as was the
custom tradition
so he was raised in all of that faith
so at the time he became of age
mark decided to go a different direction
and not stay there not stay at the farm
not stay in that community he decided to
go into the united states air force
well witness testimony is slated to pick
back up on tuesday and let's bring back
terry and gigi terry being that
mennonite is both the religion and
ethnic group could the murder of sasha
krauss be considered a hate crime
absolutely it can be considered a hate
crime both under arizona law and under
federal law under arizona law if you can
show that the crime was based on their
identity whatever that is race religion
you can call it a hate crime and it's
virtually the same under the federal law
title 18 of usc code and under that law
if it's race or religion or national
origin you can be prosecuted and in fact
you can get life in prison if it's a
murder and it's a murder based on a hate
crime so they face some serious charges
there for this individual because they
might have some evidence in fact it
looks like they do that this was based
on religion
well gigi the prosecution alleges gooch
has disdain for the mennonite community
while the defense says his childhood
foundation was built upon the religion
could that history with the church
ultimately help him or hurt him in this
trial
you know if the state is able to prove
that gooch actually did have disdain for
the community it's just going to be the
cherry on top because what's really
going to hurt him in this case are the
cell phone records are the surveillance
videos are the ballistic reports and the
financial records that are tying him to
this heinous murder
and terry it looks as though the defense
attorney has a
tall hill to climb here what kind of
things would you want to see moving
forward in this trial from the defense
side
you know the defense actually doesn't
have to even do an opening and he did
get up and do an opening and tried to
explain that his character is positive
so i think he's trying to paint a story
that this individual is a good person so
that's what the jury is hearing so far
that'll be interesting to see again the
witness testimony picks back up on
tuesday
and when we come back on earth
information in brittany's
conservatorship battle how she was
surveillance for years without her
knowledge that's coming up
[Music]
and welcome back we're now hearing from
the former law firm of attorney alec
murda who says quote he lied and stole
from us
yeah a statement to the law firm's
website says no one was aware of alec's
so-called scheme or his drug addiction
it reads in part quote we were shocked
and dismayed to learn that alex violated
our principles and code of ethics he
lied and he stole from us
all this comes weeks after the south
carolina attorney turned himself into
police admitting he orchestrated a
botched plan to kill himself
murrah claims an agreement was made to
shoot and kill him so his surviving son
would receive the proceeds from a 10
million dollar life insurance policy
murdo was shot in the head but survived
the incident back in june murda's wife
and other son were found murdered at
their south carolina family home murder
resigned from his law firm in early
september after
misappropriation of funds used to
support his opioid addiction
well now the latest news in the brittany
britney spears conservatorship battle a
new documentary alleges spear's father
monitored her calls texts and browser
history the pop star's conservatorship
began in 2008 after a string of public
meltdowns well since then her father
jamie spears has held control of her
financial decisions through a legal
conservatorship well this
conservatorship came to light in recent
years through the so-called free britney
movement as fans of the singer allege
she was being controlled by her father
in the past two years brittany has
attempted to remove her father from the
conservatorship
most recently in june of this year
alleging jamie spears was abusive and
that he ruined her life jamie spears
petitioned to be removed from the
conservatorship in early september well
a new york times documentary
now claims jamie spears asked his
daughter's security team to monitor her
every move reading text through her
icloud account and even placing a
listening device in her bedroom well
when the security employee questioned
the monitoring he was told it was for
spears own security and protection well
spears is due back in court on wednesday
for a conservative ship status hearing
let's bring back in our legal experts
gigi let's start with you brittany has
made multiple pleas to remove jamie
spears from the conservatorship and now
jamie himself will he asked to be
removed what are the odds a judge will
grant this request or vacate the
conservatorship for brittany altogether
i think it's very likely that they're
going to grant the request to remove
jamie spears from the conservatorship
considering the disturbing facts that
have come to light and the fact that the
parties are in agreement i don't see why
a judge would disagree with the party's
wishes here
yeah terry from a legal perspective
should a conservator be able to use
surveillance like this i mean this
sounds pretty disturbing her father had
a listening device in her bedroom
it is disturbing when you think about it
sima you can't invade someone's privacy
the way that her father apparently did
so she has some expectation that she's
not going to have listening devices or
someone going through her icloud so
technically you can have a conservator
over the estate or a conservator over
the person both of those are
conservatorships that are supposed to
protect the individual you aren't
supposed to be invading their privacy
and i think you can argue that there was
a conflict here as far as the father was
concerned there was no reason for him to
have information regarding her private
conversations he's supposed to be
protecting her as far as her money was
concerned and as far as some of her
medical decisions were concerned but to
get into her private conversation i
think is an invasion of privacy and a
conflict of interest
and terry the same question i asked gigi
do you think this judge will actually
grant this request
i think so i think with all of the
public outcry now with free brittany
with her father voluntarily saying he
will step down and with britney saying
she wants an into it the judge will do
so all right thank you so much ladies
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america have a
great day
[Music]
[Music]
you